[Music]
all right it's alive now something funny
is said up there about me and everybody
just claps they just start clapping just
a natural kind of thing that happens
among real americans
happy monday everyone what a great show
we have today first of all judge jeanine
is here
here she is pulling into town
[Music]
r.i.p it's the only carpool that comes
with a lifeguard
dang mcdowell is also joining us and of
course she arrived right behind the
judge
[Applause]
oh nice
she was a poor mountaineer barely kept
her family fed
so i'm thinking something really big
took place this weekend i know i'm not
talking about finally getting my wart
removed which incidentally drew more
viewers than don lemon tonight
it's not the super bowl which proved
once and for all that masks are only for
peons
no it's something the media prefers not
to cover unlike their own bloated butts
and it's about their once favorite topic
the russians except it's not their
favorite anymore judge without their
preferred storyline they buried it like
a drifter in the woods remember that
because it's no longer about trump it's
about hillary and not duff or swank or
the sexiest one of all sir edmund
take it away john scott
a shocking revelation in the durham
probe of the trump russia investigation
new filings allege that hillary
clinton's campaign paid a tech company
to infiltrate servers at trump tower and
later inside the white house to try to
create a russian collusion narrative
tech executive one and his associates
exploited this arrangement by mining the
executive office of the president's dns
traffic and other data for the purpose
of gathering derogatory information
about donald trump there you go they
didn't just do this before the election
but even after he became president it's
connected to a criminal case against
hillary's lawyer michael sussman who fed
the fbi and the cia the fake alpha bank
story remember that he's also accused of
lying when he told the fbi he wasn't
representing any client this guy makes
avenatti look like thurgood marshall
so it turns out hillary does know how a
server works except for the one that
kept her emails in a bathroom closet but
you won't hear much about that today
because the legacy media will avoid it
like a fat ugly baby
[Laughter]
case in point we went over to take a
look at what was on cnn's homepage and
here's what we found right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i could only find
something that brings me that much joy
but actually it was worse than that
their big story on cnn stating that joe
rogan's use of the n-word is another
january 6th i wonder if anyone at cnn
pulled a hamstring making that stretch
but that's cnn's definition of news when
one hysterical hoax collapses they
create another like they're a rotten
chef constantly attempting a souffle and
failing
but there's a reason why the press can't
cover this story because if they cover
it they end up having to cover their own
cover-up that's a lot of work it's the
same reason we can't get to the bottom
of any of their claims because at the
bottom is their own asinine complicity
remember this classic 60 minutes moment
the biggest scandal was when they spied
on my campaign they spied them i can't
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got it can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify turn it on because it's bad for
biden and so rather than cover the big
story bigger than january 6 watergate
and crop tops on men combined sorry
chadwick they go back to the rogan
buffet and fill up on the same old
hysterics they've just replaced trump
with joe the good news even dems see
through this according to one poll a
pile of dems want to see hillary
investigated if only to stop her from
running for president every four years
until 2084.
roughly three out of four of those polls
said they think it's important that
prosecutors investigate clinton for her
role in russia that includes 66 percent
of dems so you think the media who
caters to democrats like their royalty
would embrace this story since so many
democrats want to know more but they
can't because it calls into question the
last six years of their bogus
it exposes their corruption turns out
the trump russian collusion story was
just a deflection from the hillary
russian collusion story it's a terrific
strategy really when you're afraid of
being accused of being unfaithful just
accuse your partner first
when someone's on the defensive it's
just harder for them to come after you
for real crimes that's true the russian
story the everyone is racist story the
all-cops are bastard's narrative and the
covet story remember when it was racist
to be for the travel ban each example
deflects from something similar and
awful that the left is doing it's the
russian case in the russian case they
went hog wild for years creating
accusations conflict and anger
think of this strife the emotional cost
not to mention trump supporters being
targeted just cause their guy won of
course there needs to be a trial but no
doubt it will be ignored by the same
nincom poops yes i use that word
who drooled every time robert mueller
broke wind and who can forget this guy
do you think he'll say it's worse than
watergate
what we are watching in the trump
presidency is worse than watergate i
keep getting asked are there echoes of
watergate in this and there are we're
also witnessing something we did not see
in watergate which is a meltdown
by a president who was demonstrably
unhinged what we're seeing
is worse than watergate
what a journalistic one-hit wonder he
had a chart topper in the 70s it was
called watergate and all he does is play
it at weddings and funerals he's the
millie vanilli of commentators except
they actually had better material
of course the story barely merits aside
because so many journalists made money
got promotions landed cushy jobs because
of russia gain it was cnn's bread and
butter for years if you don't believe me
look at stelter's waistline
so now we've learned that this is way
worse than just spying some might say
it's a conspiracy to destroy a
presidency an actual threat to democracy
but those some don't work at the
networks that cause this very mess or
they might say this is indeed worse than
january 6 because it helped justify it
[Applause]
tonight's ghost she uses a gavel to
bring justice to people and to make
chicken tender before cooking it co-host
of the five judge janine pirro
[Applause]
she'll say bless your heart right before
she rips it out of you fox business
anchor teagan mcdowell
he's aggravated more gay men than a
cancelled lady gaga concert outspoken
editor chief and contributing editor of
the spectator chadwick moore
and finally for valentine's day she
crushed up her candy hearts and snorted
them off cupid's butt
fox news contributor cat tim
judge judge it's great to see you you
look fantastic can i say that yes i like
your tie too well i didn't i didn't tie
it very well today well but you wore for
valentine's day right no i didn't what
you did i worked for you
a war for you thank you for all your
women fans yes i've got millions
millions of all ages i might add yes i
have to eat them off when i leave
let's get to this topic okay you're
already annoying me what happens next
does any if you don't have a media that
pushes that this story get covered then
they don't have to cover it i'll tell
you what happens next uh apparently
some of the people involved and all of
the people involved in the creation of
that that that narrative where hillary
clinton's campaign hired people to make
it look like donald trump was working
with russia and a russian bank and
therefore is a putin asset and a a
russian
a putin pub
puppet all those people who know they're
responsible
are now shivering in their boots because
they know they've got the network now
they know they've got the causation
they've got the connection and they're
actually looking this filing that came
out is really about attorneys
representing the same
representing similar people they're
bouncing one of the attorneys off and i
think one of those attorneys might be
mark elias i couldn't be wrong about
that but you can't represent several
people who are going to be accused in
this investigation bottom line is this
they're getting close to indictments and
they will indict people are now giving
information they've got an organized
criminal enterprise this is a fraud
against the united states government
they not only tried to
surveil a campaign but actually had some
kind of surveillance in the white house
i mean this is this is an outrageous
scenario and the american people should
be furious because you mentioned it and
you're open how i mean we were in each
other's throats for years yeah and you
know and we spent all this money on
mueller who's a zero who came up with
none of this and now we've got a real
problem i mean you're right think about
that i actually murdered a family of
five during a conversation about this
and in the dagen it was like if this
thing wasn't framed like this that that
family would be alive deagon
would be alive i blame
i blame them murdering them with your
feet yes
so awesome my bare feet stomp them i
have uh my own little conspiracy theory
actually it's not even conspiracy theory
it's probably um
true
they're tr the media are trying to take
down joan rogan
because there is nothing more
frightening to them
than somebody who can't be controlled
who doesn't give
about being part of the media maroon
coven if you will somebody with 11
million viewers and listeners that if
rogan really starts digging in to the
this russia collusion hoax
i think that this is their way of trying
to silence rogan and anybody else it's
why did cnn go after
fox well cause
fox has been winning for 20 years but
it's the same thing that they don't want
a light shined on
the media malfeasance
of covering up for clinton and pushing
this because this is goes beyond just
the the russia hoax and what was going
on leading up to the election but it
also extended into trump's tenure which
is essentially a coup and like why are
liz cheney and
adam kensinger why are they having this
holier than now january 6th committee
and they like their new friends they
like their new friends it is a riot i
understand that but there's plenty of
videotape why not have some hearings
yeah about
you know with clinton people people
human beings like new friends
especially if the new friends hated them
at first so they're getting the strange
new respect from the democrats that
makes them feel really good and they
they're going like it's more fun to have
a liberal like me than have my old
republican friends hanging out with me
chadwick is this worse than watergate
well the court filings
you're supposed to say yes yes thank you
you're always right you know uh the
court filing says
very clearly that president trump was
spied on in the white house yes and i
heard you know richard grinnell who was
at dni said this very same thing
how the hell do you spy on the white
house without help from someone inside
the government
i mean that i think is the biggest uh
what might come to light and the most
terrifying thing someone who inside
government knew about this who was in on
it and who helped the spying um but
you're correct barack obama or shall i
say barack
hussein obama
well what would obama and joe biden know
during when the campaign was spying on
trump also yes you know yeah
will they be indicted or brought into
this who knows yeah this is very very
interesting kat
have you uh recovered from your weekend
of super bowl mania it's so bad yes i
was gonna ask them to change the channel
at the bar
that's true i was there
everyone said no we like this
[Laughter]
there's some variation did you have any
relationships or uh parts of your life
that were damaged by this this
incredible hoax
yes i mean
obviously i think everybody has
um and what's crazy about this not being
covered is like
you know these are court documents from
a federal prosecutor which is like a
step or two above anonymous sources say
but they love those yes they love those
they love those i got four years of them
yeah and it's that jump all over that
but not this and you know i get that
they're busy because they have to
connect joe rogan to not only january 6
but the genocide in rwanda in 1994.
that was that article said like there's
going to be genocide because i mean like
that is a jump i'm i consider myself a
creative person i don't think i could
have thought of that no that was pretty
imp i was impressed by that right the
writing there i mean it was awful but
you got to be a particularly bad bad
kind of writer like so many people are
like dumb and like do dumb things but so
few are like snooky where they could
become richer than i'll i'll ever be off
of that this is like a version of that
yeah he was an intellectual snooki no he
was a actually you know he was a dumb
version of snooki because snooki is
brilliant one of the uh the great minds
of the 21st century hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else